the first question I had for you not on
the not on the paper is if I want to
start a cult-like mustache ian's what
are your pro tips and that's a good
question and if I had prepared I would
have brought my little talk that I gave
a few years ago at a blogger conference
that was called don't start a blog start
a cult but anyway I think the pro tips
are you need to have a identifiable
philosophy that's maybe a bit different
than what the normal world is into so
because your people your cult members
are gonna organize around this cult so
you maybe want just a little bit of a
feeling of us versus them and like oh we
are you know we got these values and
they're noble but but the other outside
world doesn't quite support us we're a
little bit oppressed so then you have
the sense of identity and then this is
all stuff I stumbled on accidentally
because really I was just saying here's
a good idea for a living yeah and then
other people like yeah I like that idea
too but nobody agrees with me so that's
why I accidentally had the slightly cult
thing going on and other things that are
useful you know a couple more pro tips
would include like use of terminology
and silly words and that's true with
like whether you're the cult of Star
Trek or iPhone or the various religions
they all have these sort of special
terminology and it helps to have an
identifiable leader too so I've called
it and which I am better or worse she
came yeah but you got Steve Jobs or
Captain Kirk or the leaders of the
religions or the gods all this stuff is
is handy for creating cult people think
of a cult is a bad thing because they're
thinking of Waco Texas and kool-aid but
really it's just a social organization
structure which is a basic built in
thing to human beings and it's what
allows us to live together and cooperate
so if you can make your brand or your
company or your blog have these
cult-like
properties then that's probably a good
thing for making it last and have a
having a real audience how do you feel
about the cult of Elon Musk well I'm
part of it okay
I think that's uh I'm gonna have a
biased answer but it certainly fits the
description that we were saying that I
was just saying now about what a cult is
and it's he's definitely an identifiable
leader he's definitely got unusual ideas
but the reason I and so much in this
cult is everything that guy says or
writes I just agree with it so almost
fully and I really like the way he
explained stuff it's like that finally
someone is running a company and instead
of just spewing like this corporate
[ __ ] like we are considering the
needs of our customers we will get back
you know he's always like no I think it
was a bug in like the 3.0 software we'll
get a release out yeah next week you
know like it's proper he speaks like a
combination of an engineer but with a
much bigger perspective on everything
and he has these clear goals so that's
why I'm so favored you know and so far
he's done very little like evil yeah you
know like maybe he has personal issues
in the sense that he's so driven that
it's hard to relate to deal on musk if
you work directly for him but his
overall goals seem to be absolutely
spot-on for you know a good person
that's a kind of cult I want to be on
well I was curious if the cult leader
you know needs to be like somewhat
maniacal in their pursuit like they have
to be polarizing to a certain extent
probably a little bit or they at least
have to be so convinced that their way
is is the way or a viable way that
they're going to get some disagreement
from some people you know in my personal
views for example have become more
hardcore over the last year that cars
are just like the biggest stupid
inefficiency that we have in United
States and we need to just cut that
whole [ __ ] down by at least 90 percent
and because 99 percent of people are
completely car dependent that makes me a
polarizing figure this bicycle sandals
men trying to tell me to do like it's
just so different from anything I can
imagine so in that way that might be
actually enhancing my status as an
imaginary cult yeah well are you are you
excited about soft
in Karzai I get the sense sometimes that
they're just going to encourage mega
commutes oh yeah that's a good question
yeah even though it's a slight you know
jump I guess you were thinking Elon Musk
and then you thought self-driving cars
so I think there are like a tool but not
the only tool and right now this is the
only place I disagree with the Elon Musk
vision is that a car should be thought
of as like a luxury racing wheelchair
okay so there's times in your life you
want a luxury racing wheelchair for
example when you're with your friends
and you're all going up into the
mountains and like high altitude and a
blizzard and you want to have some beers
and your snowboards are in the back
perfect time for a car but if you just
want to go to work for miles or even 40
miles there's better ways to design your
life you know don't go 40 miles to work
and so yeah if we can keep the
self-driving cars around so that they
can reduce our crash rate and they can
make our cities not be filled with
inefficient parking lots mm-hmm and
that's a win but if you're just doing a
mega commute from like Pleasanton over
to San Francisco or something not to Los
and you're still wasting all this land
to make giant roads and the cars
themselves take way too much space
because they're bigger than one person
so I would hope that we can go both ways
like denser cities bike friendly and
then self-driving cars to eliminate the
dumb stuff we do with cars now so we'll
see so one of the questions I was
wondering is you have a lot of software
engineer you know cult members or
followers like entry-level cult member
just call them readers now scaring
people off with the cult label one of
the questions I was curious about is you
know for people who are interested in
retiring early or saving more of their
money you know if you're living in a big
city and say you're making like 30 grand
what is your advice for people like that
yeah because I know it's easier when
you're making 150 to save say more than
money yeah
well it's good to figure out why you're
in that city in the first place because
you can make $30,000 anywhere including
a really affordable
places or even working from home and I
mean like the location of your choice in
other countries so that's the first
thing it's like are you willing to pay
the premium to live in that city if
you're actually going to make that wage
that you could make just you know
working as a manager at a at a fast food
place or something and then the second
choice is or the second answer is if
that answer is yes or regardless of the
answer what are you going to do with
that money because there's always hacks
you can do to get your living to be
cheap or to get your food to be cheap
there's a lot of people who live in San
Francisco for little to no rent just
through special arrangements like
they're friends with somebody who has a
space or they're trading services for
rent or they own a place and then Airbnb
out the rest of it or whatever so the
less you earn in your regular job the
more valuable your time becomes in in
these frugality hacks of cutting down
your expenses and figuring out how to
get around for free and where to get the
food that is good for you but not super
expensive did you have a special
arrangement because you moved to
Colorado from Canada when you were just
out of school yeah no I was I worked a
few years in Canada first and so I did
do a few things
even back then like instead of seeking
out my own apartment I was always
splitting this he's nicer bigger houses
I would go on to the equivalent of
Craigslist back then they use net groups
find stuff for rent go they're liking my
best clothes and so yeah we would like
to rent this place as several
professionals young professionals that
would like to use the bedrooms and then
the owners are like okay I guess we'll
lent you our fancy house and then all
the all the boys would move in and they
were my co co-workers as engineers that
were friends so we'd split a four
bedroom place among like four guys for
example and then we would each pay $300
a month at the time when an apartment by
yourself might be 700 so it was a
win-win because we would have a much
nicer place with a huge kitchen a nice
backyard and then but for less cost then
then you'd pay for a junky beige
apartment and unlike the 13th floor so I
did that from the beginning and then
when I moved to the u.s. even back at
the time I was probably making
in today's dollars like close to
$100,000 I still went straight to
Craigslist and got a roommate situation
for the first year because I had to save
up a down payment and eventually I
bought a house and then I've chosen to
live in houses that I owned since then
but it's not necessary I could still do
rentals we just you know we spend more
on our housing because we find it to be
a nice luxury it's one of our many
indulgences now that you're at that
point to afford it yes and you know
earlier like long before retirement we
still chose to live in a house my
girlfriend and I now wife so yeah we
knew that it's just something that was
worth it to us and because I like
working on houses it kind of paid for it
as well because I was increasing the
value in my hobby time which makes it
easier to sell your house for more later
mm-hmm and throughout this process we're
like you know when you're just starting
to work did you just happen to have you
know you weren't spending the money so
you were just looking for ways to take
advantage of it as you were saving it
like why did you why did you start
connecting the dots and realize like
what cost you to realize it that you
could retire early I probably started
fairly early because I was a kid I was I
used to like I earn my dollar bills when
I was a kid and put him in a photo album
I paid $5 for cutting the grass I'd iron
that five and stick it in so I liked
money as a concept even when I was young
and then as I earned more money
throughout my minimum-wage jobs I would
not spend it all and although I did tend
to blow it at the time because I didn't
know about investment so I would save up
a bunch and then I'd buy like a dirt
bike or motorcycle and then I'd save up
for another year and then buy really
expensive stereo system or whatever but
then eventually one of those things was
paying for my education you know I saved
up for the first year of tuition so I
was getting a bit more reasonable but
then at around 19 someone handed me like
I think there's like a wealthy
acquaintance of one of my sisters handed
me this book on investing and wealth
building and I was like burned through
that whole thing in one day and then I
thought whoa investing is good so then I
kept reading books like that and then I
realized something else you could do
with money
ya know by the time I was in my twenties
it made sense that this
surplus money would just go into
investments and at the time to me that
just meant stock investments and then I
didn't do anything specially smart with
them but over after reading more books
over the years I started to do less dumb
things and then that's why I kind of
settled on this index fund a model
mm-hmm for stock investing nowadays in
in that process of you know learning how
to invest and getting going and then
actually saving like what fifty percent
sixty seventy percent of your income
something like that yeah that's what it
was towards the end we got over into the
60s because our income was going up
about our household spending wasn't
going up yeah well well what did that
feel like socializing because we you
know we posted this to Twitter before we
did the interview and a lot of people
were really curious about the the social
implications of you know you're trying
to put away fifty percent while your
friends you know your co-workers make
the same amount of money roughly what
was that like well at our level it was
pretty easy you know to be honest it's
kind of privileged when you have two
tech salaries you don't really have to
give up any visible stuff in order you
can still go out to dinner you can still
have a ski pass and go skiing and
everything it was more on the hidden
stuff that we cut out for example we
would keep the same bike instead of
upgrading our bikes all the time and we
would eat at eat lunch at our workplaces
instead of going out to work and driving
around all the time and waiting an hour
just to say you could spend $20.00 for
lunch those kind of things don't cost
you anything in social fun but they're
just more efficient and similar with
cars like we would keep our used cars
and our friends would buy new cars your
friends don't care what kind of car you
have so you're not you're not getting
any social cost by keeping your Honda
Civic when your friends have like a
brand new you know top-of-the-line
BMW so note there's basically no pain
yeah I think this address is like the
the issue or rather the reason why so
many people like your blog it just feels
much more relatable than many of the
other early retirement blogs which you
know like live in your van eat ramen
noodles forever where those around as
you started to save money and you just
found it inaccessible or did you not
even realize that that was a thing
right I didn't even know yet it existed
to be honest and and there weren't
really many blogs until the mid 2000s
maybe and that's when I retired so I
just did everything and according to my
own strange values and then retired
roughly like it just before it turned 31
so that's why I still claim I retired at
30 and then lived that way for about six
years before even thinking of writing
this down in the form of a blog and then
when I did eventually I went to the
search engine and I typed like early
retirement for gala tea and then there
was this blog called early retirement
extreme by this super great frugal guy
named Jacob and I was like crap I can't
start a blog this is already covered
yeah so I totally I'm not gonna waste my
time duplicating it but then I read his
his whole blog and I'd already written a
bunch of articles kind of in advance
just stuff that I wanted to tell people
and turned out that we had different
takes significantly enough that I
thought I was still worth publishing
yeah and then Jacob and I ended up
communicating quite a bit since then
over the years oh yeah I'm glad I
published but there weren't nearly as
many financial and retirement blogs even
when I started in 2011 then there are
now I feel like now we have thousands of
them who are you looking up to at the
time I don't know if I really operate on
a role-model basis like that I'm kind of
more of a strange like floating around
by myself in the ideas sphere so like I
read books I was interested in in the
ideas in for example investing books
yeah but I didn't really have any
personal life style role models because
I didn't read any blogs it was just you
know I'm just an independent guy I had
local friends family and I still don't
really have any role models I clearly
identify with and copy I'm just
interested if people are good at stuff
they're doing like the Elon Musk example
we used before then I I follow their
their progress and I think oh yeah
that's a good idea hmm
but it's so different from the quest
that I'm on that I don't really have any
role models exactly like in how to be
mister money mustache
in the end there wasn't even someone who
you found was was kind of blazing their
own Trail and you're like oh you know
even like family members were like oh
they kind of got it figured out they're
doing their own thing oh no I think
that's maybe one of my advantages and
disadvantages in life is that I don't
even really look around to see what
other people are doing I just have these
opinions and sometimes they're
considered quite crazy
yeah other times people find use in what
I do but I I'm kind of this maybe I'm
like a first principles person where I
just look at something and I'm like well
that's [ __ ] I'm not gonna do that
yeah and other times I look at other
things and I follow it and yeah
sometimes that gets me I'm a misfit in
society because of this you know like
giving finding stuff to by people
exactly on their birthday for example I
don't understand that tradition so I
don't do it and then other people who
you know who expect that they're like
guys not very thoughtful he don't get me
yeah but I'll get I'll do stuff for
people when I when I think of something
they need or some service or help they
need so I'll do it
whenever not I don't align it with the
calendar stuff so that's one example I
never understood fancy weddings is
another one like I think marriage is a
fine thing and parties are great things
so having a party for your marriage is
great but the whole thing with like
special flowers and arrange but some
table stuff that seemed like nonsense to
me special and wedding rings all America
yeah you're not wearing a wedding ring
yeah yeah that's true
well I'm not against wedding rings but
what I was thinking is the engagement
ring with the whole tradition with like
diamonds and expenses I came across that
later in life and I was like man that is
total total nonsense like why where'd
this tradition come from so I just
totally rejected it luckily my
girlfriend at the time also was a
rejecter of that so it didn't cost me
this is a super common question people
are like you know I'm you know following
mister money mustache or anyone and or
I'm just personally like like you like
I'm just on my own interested in tiling
retiring early interested in saving
money how do I get a partner on board oh
yeah you have thoughts there and well it
helps to pick that person in advance
like there's three strategies you are
already committed to somebody who has
certain values and then that can go
either way they may be flexible they may
be diametrically opposed to you on this
stuff
and so you got to figure that out
separately but if you're still looking
for a person or like in the circulating
dating stage finding someone who has
these similar lifestyle values is
awesome and I've met so many couples now
that are of that style and they really
are they get along well mm-hmm that's
why intra moustache Ian inter moustache
Ian dating is really a good thing and
when I want to have these events now and
I see people getting together or even
like on the forum through my website a
second together yeah yeah and actually
there is an app coming out made by money
mustache readers and the joke is that
it's going to include a mustache Ian
tinder feature it's great um and I was
really adamant that that is a valuable
thing yes people want to meet each other
and when they do when single mustache
ian's meet each other which sounds silly
because if you don't understand the word
mustache E and they're like well that's
just that's just silly but basically
what it really means is unusually
thoughtful people that some have certain
personality traits in common and they're
often like to be honest quite clever
because they're drawn from like tech
workers or well-educated people for
whatever reason that type of person has
a hard time finding their same type
especially ones that aren't blown out
completely in consumerism and spending
all their money and no concern for
environmental or resource stuff so when
they meet each other the sparks really
fly so you might as well make that
easier if you're in my position I would
love to see good relationships like that
forming why do you think the we talked
about this a little bit but why are
engineer types why are these clever
types as you is you put interested in
mister money mustache or interested in
early retirement
maybe because they they like things to
be logical and they might have the same
tunnel vision that I have in the sense
that they they
don't just follow social norms they try
to evaluate things on a case-by-case
basis like do I like this tradition of
society you know or do I like this one
and when they see somebody going through
that same thought process they resonates
with them because that's not what you
it's not the same type of thing you'll
see in like CNN news or you know or
television shows and stuff maybe now
with you but yeah yeah if moustache Ian
is on CNN news but everything else is
very much like let's take society as it
is and then just talk about it whereas
moustache in principles is more like
let's take human nature based on what we
understand as a science and adjust our
lives so that it they work well with our
nature you know so the society is kind
of irrelevant that's more like a
byproduct that's just formed through
random processes and you don't have to
follow that I mean if your goal is
happiness just understand yourself as a
creature every podcast always boils down
to this concept of it yeah which might
as well just get into it right now yeah
and your self as a creature and what's
your goal well that's living a happy
life what does that mean it means having
a series of happy days and then figure
out how to have the experiences in your
life that lead to as many happy days as
possible and that's not gonna be that's
not gonna come from like car upgrades or
following lame social traditions it's
more about thinking deeply about what
makes you happy and then doing it and
it's it's not like what makes me happy
is different from him or her like we
actually have much more overlap in what
makes us happy then we would care to
admit mm-hmm so that's where some of
these fundamentals really get useful you
know so yeah I mean given that obviously
you like doing construction you know
we're at the HQ which we should talk
about but with happiness if if more
things aren't in common than we think
what are the things that make you happy
and especially in the longer because
like you know if I eating pizza makes me
happy but that's not like my retirement
strategy yeah yeah I'd say eating pizza
doesn't make you happy
eating pizza you know it makes you have
like goods like sensual experiences you
know like your salt
sugar buds are all like nicely tangled
but if you if you measure what happens
in your happiness after like increasing
your pizza consumption so to do like a
little experiment in yourself
are you actually happier after a
month-long of eating more pizza and
because it because there's other factors
right there's your health and there's
your activities you gave up in order to
eat pizza and foods and everything so
the stuff we have in common though is we
we have genuine social needs of a
varying degree so we like to be
connected with people we like to smile
at people and feel valued so that's
that's a social side which many people
say is the most important so you you
want to feel like you're part of a
community and that people value you and
that you're contributing to that
community you're not just taking and it
really helps to read books on this stuff
so if you can find books on somewhat
scientifically based thanks for human
happiness just grab them from the
library and read through them because it
chances are it'll blow your mind if you
haven't been studying this all right so
then secondly there's things like your
personal health affects your happiness
because it just changes the level of
stuff that's circulating your brain like
just the plain old dopamine and related
chemicals or like walking eating salads
it sounds kind of boring but it
genuinely makes you happier and third on
the self-actualization level like being
able to create stuff that you're proud
of mm-hmm so working on something that's
difficult overcoming challenges and then
having something to show for it at the
end and then continually doing that
that's a really big Happiness boosting
activity so and that's why TV shows
watching TV is not a life boosting
activity to a certain extent it might
have a second-order effect of boosting
happiness because you might get to talk
about TV shows with your friends so then
you're creating that social bond but if
you throw that away and instead for
example using the construction example I
solve problems in my little construction
projects and I do a lot of stuff with my
physical body which makes me healthier
and then I can bond over those
activities with my other friends who are
into that like my carpenter friends or I
have a lot of kind of Renaissance man
friends you know who like carpentry but
they also like nerdy science experiments
and and money and engineering so we can
bond over like all the stuff we did in
our construction projects and how that
became a great rental house yeah and how
that became led to these neat
experiences and then what the neighbors
did in response so you get all the whole
Happiness Project satisfied all pressing
all the happiness buttons yeah and
that's why I keep doing construction is
it's for me it's like this super
smoothie like this or thing that I can
chug that makes me happy in so many ways
and you kind of compartmentalize it we
were talking earlier before I recorded
about doing this alone and it's
similarities to engineering like the
time it takes to get into a flow state
and you know you need like a block of
time right um do you try and you know
like combine this stuff or you've just
found it's much more satisfying to kind
of you know this is your social check
box this is your like hard work you know
working out or carpentry or whatever it
might yeah yeah I do try to put it in
separate sections yeah and make sure
they're all addressed so because it's
daily routines kind of make things
happen automatically and when you don't
have a daily routine it's easy to forget
stuff that's important to you so I've
got I've been in for at least the last
six months since I bought this place
I've been a pretty neat daily routine
where I get up have a healthy breakfast
bike downtown where this building is and
then work for three or four hours
typically early when my family's still
asleep for part of that time so I'm so
I'm getting all these buttons pressed
like physical health problem-solving you
know having time to and I always listen
to really good music will I do this too
so it's kind of like a nice Zen flow
state and then you have something to
show for it at the end of it you have
more of your building done and you can
be like I can imagine people are going
to enjoy this feature later on when we
open it up yeah and then I bike back
home and then I do family time where
like I'm helping with my son and raising
him and you know being a good dad and
all that stuff mm-hmm and then later on
in the day it'll be you might have
friends over or do some stuff to help
your friends okay with their projects
yeah cuz that was a question from
Twitter David lang I maybe been
mispronouncing he's basically asking you
know prior to HQ construction
did you have trouble finding this
routine in your nine-to-five Yeah right
like the daily routine yeah when I do
have a daily routine that's when I am
happiest I find because I've been
retired for a long time so I've kind of
had ups and downs longer than you were
working right I might be at this point
yeah okay so full-time well in 12 years
yeah I've been 12 years since I quit
real work and then my total of work
career was about 9 or 10 years depending
how you count for the early years so
you're right and the times that I've
been most happy have been when I have a
routine like right now I'm kind of on a
you know really nice high point of my
life's happiness I would say over the
last 6 months and especially this month
hmm I never live any downs but I have
like different levels of up so this is a
really high level of up and I think it's
because the routine has been really
solid like just super yeah physical lots
of healthy stuff not a lot of
self-destructive things going on well
you're also bringing people together
like you just had two weeks of the
pop-up Business School you know how many
other people get started like it's all
converging like you're building a place
to socialize yeah that's true so that
really takes care of the social side
because I had 85 people that I was
hosting here in this building so lots of
talking and seeing other people be happy
yeah so that's obviously a pretty big
advantage in making you feel like your
life is worthwhile if you're surrounded
by wonderful people yeah who in there
your life's kind of buzzing with
activity in fact it got to be too much
for a while and I had to take a whole
weekend of just like sleeping in and
eating salads because there was no
productive personal time which is which
I find is one of my building blocks is
like I need to do stuff alone and think
and plan and and have time for all the
thoughts to kind of go together and
that's because I'm kind of a partial
introvert in in recovery time according
to the Susan Cain but quiet is i
recharge with quiet time whereas other
people might recharge from like a Denver
Broncos game or something like that
yeah I'm the same way do you do much
long-term planning because obviously you
know within the next year
this place will be mostly completed
right
do you plan on what happens after that I
have a lot of tentative long-term plans
like I liked the idea of maybe expanding
this place to take over another building
so that we can just have a bigger
co-working space or and then in a longer
term I have a bunch of maybe ideas like
can we start a town that's founded by on
mustache Ian's principles instead of car
principles yeah but I don't put dates on
these things until I'm really ready so I
try to avoid like Oh next year do you
want to do something huge then I say
well let's find out let's ask our each
other next year until yeah and if we
still like it and we'll put it like a
week into our calendars a week in the
future
okay so I get stressed out a little bit
with too much stuff on my calendar
yeah there's one thing that makes me
different than most people I've learned
is I don't like planning lunch for next
week or three weeks from now I like
planning stuff less than 24 hours in
advance according to a bigger picture
though well I appreciate you scheduling
this a couple we had events this was
definitely an exception but I just
figured you know because there's nothing
else I have planned this week then it's
probably okay for Craig to come over
odd cast but it could have gone either
way you know I could have last night
been like [ __ ] I can't believe I told
Craig to come over the pocket I can't do
that I have other stuff to do I could
just take a weird turn right now so a
handful of people asked online like what
is the plan for the co-working space the
mustache and co-working space are you
going to expand our into other locations
not just literally the building like
other cities yeah not similar to the
question we just talked about yes in
theory it sounds good I definitely don't
want to make any fixed plans on it
especially this is the first Monday the
co-working space has even been open and
there's normal people to just pop in and
do some work so it's if it continues to
be fun for at least maybe six months or
something okay or three even then we'll
know if if it's worthwhile expanding and
if it did then I can personally expand
this to another building mm-hmm and then
another person asked in the question
list can we franchise this because they
liked the idea of one being in their
town and the answer to that is
probably as long as I don't have to do
any of the work for it if we just come
up with principles that work for ya what
we're now calling triple m headquarters
and the principles are really just like
a place to hang out and you're not
milking people for as much money as you
can by running it sort of cooperatively
based then yeah people can open them
other way other places and I would
support them in the sense of like making
a directory yeah of them so people can
share with their community the biggest
obstacle to making this in any town is
that you have to reach the people who
are interested and I had this advantage
that I could just type some [ __ ] into
the computer and then people immediately
signed up as well and that's like a blog
is a really really useful thing for
creating yeah groups of people and if
the other people starting it don't have
their own blog that means my job would
be to use mine blog which is
collectively yeah help everybody who
reads it to find the places well that
was kind of related to another question
on the expansion of moustachy anism so
lee marshall asks if everyone in the
world adopted it would it help or hurt
the us but i mean i think you can expand
that to the whole world yeah yeah it
depends on your definition of what
they're adopting and early in the days
of the blog people would say well if
everybody just put all their money in
index funds and then quit working and
then never did anything again productive
that would wreck our economy and then in
that case I do agree because that would
be there would be no workers in the
system and the stock values would be
inflated because we write a demand for
it and yeah of course that's not
sustainable but that's not really the
definition of moustachy anism or not
even for gala tea so what really happens
is I'm an anti waste blog really like
I'm not against spending money but I'm
against wasting money especially when
there's external effects so like if
someone says should I fill up my forty
gallon diesel pickup truck and then
drive up into the mountains to go ATVing
all day no that's a waste in so many
ways you know you're burning up these
vehicles you're burning up the fuel
you're not getting any physical exercise
and you're wrecking everybody else's
life on the planet so if you if less of
that type
stuff happened that doesn't hurt our
economy at all it just shrinks the
fossil fuel section and the recreational
motor vehicle section which I would
argue are just drains on human
productivity really now instead if we
spend our money on things like clean
energy systems you know like instead of
going ATVing you could figure out solar
panels and install them on your garage
like like I've done here that's just one
like kind of really overly obvious
example or you could spend your money
and time fixing stuff in your town that
also brings you a lot of social fun and
exercise and things and you might build
trails and so anyway when you have when
you get a lot of money saved up and
invested yeah that's just really a
psychological you know springboard to
give you the freedom to do what you want
to do with your life okay but very few
people quit being productive at that
point they're they just quit a job if
they don't like it yeah and then they
typically will start another business
doing something they like or they'll
start volunteering more or start being
an interesting better person in some
other way
yeah well that was that was actually one
of the things that I also was interested
in you know you were just saving the
money while you were working and I think
what's more common is to start a
business right you know you're like okay
I have 200k in the bank
I can just go I forgot the exact wording
of the question yeah I mean it's greener
pastures asked how do you balance
moustachy and frugality with spending to
start and grow a business yeah that's a
good question and if you think about
moustachy and principles in starting a
business you might be more efficient in
it for example you'd say okay I have a
flower delivery business a normal person
might be saying like okay I'm gonna buy
the biggest six wheel pickup truck that
I can and then put one little flower and
the truck bed and drive that around
because that's a business vehicle and
moustachy and I'll say well I'm just
gonna buy like a they used Ford Transit
Connect these little like van cars that
are efficient and cheap on the use
market and so they're both accomplishing
the same thing and in flower delivery
mm-hmm but one of them is spending six
times more money than the other one so
so that's that's one one partial answer
to the question and then the other thing
is if you think about cash flow quickly
in your business instead of like years
of investment in in hopes of finding
your first customer that's more of a
risk to your money whereas if you think
how can I start my business small and go
right to sales and then scale up only
after I've proven it with sales
that's that reduces your your risk and
that's kind of what the pop-up business
goal was about as well yeah so one
example that I didn't follow and I wish
I had is when I quit working I
immediately started a construction
company because I said I love building
stuff in designing houses and I'm gonna
make some good I guess the style yeah
yeah so so we borrowed money to buy land
and then borrowed money to build these
big 3,000 square foot houses and then
they had to sell before you could even
get your money back let alone make a
profit much better design much better
design for business would have been just
grab your tool belt and make sure you
have good tools with almost no
investment and then find customers to do
stylish renovations on their houses and
then watch that cash flow build up and
if you still like it then maybe you
expand to building custom houses for
existing people where they buy the land
and they hire you as a builder mm-hm and
then if you like that then you might
choose to expand by buying land of doing
the craziest thing but that would be
only once you have so much money saved
from it and so much confidence that it's
not a big risk anymore right and so it's
yeah it's all about lowering the risk
and getting feedback that way all right
and I sure didn't know that when I first
even though I was supposedly kind of
wise enough to have an early retirement
I still blew it when it came to starting
my own business and it was stressful and
terrible and I lost a friend out of it
quote the business partner so so yeah
it's you don't you don't automatically
know everything do you get involved on
the other side so Gabe AI I just a
Twitter handle asked you what you
thought about angel investing do you do
you ever get involved in that it sounds
neat I have a this guy named a friend
named Nords who has the early retirement
for military retirees yeah blog and he
talks about angel investing all the time
and it sounds great but
his stories are the only thing I know
about it so apparently it's a good use
of you can think of it as like a
business starting philanthropy if you
don't make money on it and then you can
make money on it maybe as well I'm very
good at it
but he says you should think of your
first hundred thousand dollars or more
as tuition in angel investing school so
I think it's a good use if you have the
money but I wouldn't advise people to
think of it as a money-making technique
unless they are passionate enough about
it to be quite good at it mm-hmm okay
and so basically what you do advise
people and another person Laurent asks
basically what are the skills that
someone ought to build up it's just at
the bottom of that one you know
obviously you're your pro Vanguard index
funds right so that's an investment
strategy your pro carpentry construction
skills what are the other skills you
advise someone to learn I would say get
good at anything that you get good at
producing anything that you like
consuming especially if it's expensive
so you might not care about getting good
at producing lettuce for example unless
you're you're passionate about it but if
you really like having a car then you
should get good at understanding cars
and how to buy them and how to maintain
them if if you drive enough that
maintenance is an issue and then that
part of your life can become free or
even profitable if you don't really care
about cars and use them very much then
you might skip that skill and for
example just use bikes or just have a
cheap car that you minimally you put
minimal money into it and I'm I'm
passionate about housing are like spaces
and having a cool place for people to
hang out and to host gatherings so
because of that my skill at producing
housing or buildings and maintaining
them is more valuable than it would be
for somebody who doesn't care about it
because I can create these things and I
get houses effectively for free because
by putting by finding them cheap and
putting my labor into them then they can
become profitable mm-hmm so yeah basic
skills instead of saying everybody
should have the same basic skills it
should it should really align with what
you like to do
I mean I guess cooking might be kind of
a universal one because everybody yeah
yeah so if you're really shitty at
creating food but you really want to eat
expensive food all the time and you just
go to restaurants for it yeah that's a
fundamental tax on your life unless
you're good at making the money for that
but most people specialize in buying
restaurant meals and they don't have
much income so that's a misalignment so
it's no good and then what what about if
you have kids where you what skills are
you focusing on teaching your son oh
yeah so that's a good one and kind of
like the last question so learning about
parenting is a good thing if you have
kids and yeah not following the
necessarily the social norms about
raising kids because at least in wealthy
areas of the US there's this really
weird tradition where people like to
book up their kids and just have them do
stuff all the time like paid activities
and you have to drive them around town
and that makes no sense at all to me
because kids are learning machines like
the reason kids are different than
adults and the reason I like playing and
playing with each other and stuff is is
because that's how they learn best is
they need to be in an environment where
they're stimulating stuff that they can
figure out how it works and have new
experiences and none of that is part of
of kid hit evolutionary history like you
know a forest or this is why Lego is a
good tool as it recreates a forest
yeah stuff that you can put together to
create different experiences so I would
say if you're if you have kids learn
about learning and don't fall into the
trap of booking up your kid's life with
organized activities because then you're
depriving them of all the real learning
that that they're built to do and do you
have any like force mechanisms ensure
they're physically active or are you
just kind of you know you do stuff and
he does stuff with you and that's just
how it goes yeah I try to make it I try
to make that happen because my son is
very mentally based like he loves
computers and he loves computers
so because he's 11 now so I try to but
he also we get along really well so he
loves his dad so I try to make myself
not available for computer activities
with them and if he wants to do stuff
with me has to be physical so I'm like
well we can go play frisbee in the park
behind our house or we can go down and
play at the creek where we like bike
down to this Natural Area and do forest
jungle jungle guy stuff and so that's
what how we get physical stuff more and
you know we encourage friends to do
sporty things with him and yeah some
kids are naturally drawn to team sports
and in that case you should support it
but my son is like me and that he he
doesn't he just doesn't go for it he's
like well why would I obey an adult's
rules on how to play a game like that's
that's lame I want to invent my own game
okay so I was always like that as a kid
too so I have to have sympathy for that
yeah I'm definitely a solo sport kind of
person as well yeah so he likes biking
and he likes tree climbing and he
hopefully he likes being strong I think
that's the real thing that will keep you
out of trouble as you grow up is if you
have a desire to be healthy and strong
then that that'll affect your your
habits through the rest of your teenage
years I was kind of inspired as a kid by
like Arnold movies and stuff really yeah
because I like the idea of like the
tough confident man you know as a kid
because I was nerdy so so that made got
me into like the whole physical training
bodybuilding stuff yeah and not that I
was like a bodybuilder but that was just
inspiring to me so I lived that way
where I was like you know getting
exercise and working on my health and
stuff and that really helped me avoid
stuff that happens to people at my age
now if I hadn't been like that
throughout my life yeah one pound a year
and then it's a lot I'm 22 so yeah right
yeah and so what about a what about his
education do you have any thoughts on
you know should he go to college should
he focus on you know obviously he's into
computers should you be an engineer do
you do you guide him in any way there I
would say no like we definitely have
explained
the university model and why it was good
for us the parents and and then it's up
to him to decide if it's good for him
because the stuff has changed so much
the world of jobs and businesses the
Internet has blown it apart to degree
that most people don't understand but as
I've become more of an Internet person
myself and I see all the businesses that
exist out there it turns out almost
everything is possible
mmm without schooling formal schooling
you can probably do it better and learn
it better yourself it's only like the
most traditional professions now like
medicine and other like certain types of
law that you acquire this really formal
stuff yeah and if you're a self guided
person like I think my son is he might
not have the patience or the desire to
go into any kind of traditional thing
he's like I want to create what I want
to create and sell it to whoever is
interested in it yeah so I don't mind if
he doesn't go to formal university if he
does I'll definitely support him in that
way too but I would never force him
because you know where he's it's so easy
to make a living in so many different
ways that it's not there's no stress
like oh you got to do this or you're
gonna be in the ditch okay living and
but I support him you mean support him
not financially you mean mentally I'm
just like well I I mean we would
certainly pay for whatever needs to be
paid for he wanted to go to a fancy
liberal arts you know seventy thousand
or a hundred thousand dollar-a-year
school by the time he's 18 you're like
all right I'm in well if there was we
were talk about that with them okay like
I mean first of all I think it's good
for kids to pay for their own education
to the most degree that they can because
you it's good to understand the money
part of it secondly that sounds like
kind of a you know that's beyond cuz
school kind of has like this exponential
thing at the top of the cost where you
get into ridiculous costs for no reason
like the private ones mm-hmm whereas you
can go to like the Harvard the Ivy
League schools for pretty much free if
you're good enough to get in then you
generally don't have to pay a huge
amount to to do it so that would be
another thing I didn't
but let's say hypothetically like the
only path that will make him have the
best life is to pay the super tuition
for this thing and he can't pay for
himself then yes we would pay for it
okay you know in this situation because
we've come in to extra money in our old
situation if I hadn't you know if I was
living off $25,000 a year and just had
like the 1 million dollars of savings
and had never done any more work mm-hmm
to build it then we would say no we
can't afford it so we're not gonna go
into debt to pay for your school okay I
think that's a valid thing for parents
to do they should not pretend that
they're multimillionaires just because
that's the American Standard people
should pay for they should buy the
schooling that they can afford I think
it's really valuable for a kid to figure
out how much it actually costs before
you you know sign it like yeah this
month is my last month of expensive nyu
student loan payments and so it's become
much clearer how expensive it was those
four years yeah after the fact yeah
people really students don't really see
the dollars I just see it like vaguely
in December yeah yeah and I think you
should learn that from the beginning I
remember my first year of school which I
was paying for mostly myself I went in
with the attitude that you probably did
where I was like oh yeah I guess these
are the books I need I'll just put them
on the on the account or whatever and
then I was like vaguely had this vague
feeling man this physics textbook is $89
that sounds like a lot but I guess
that's what you do yeah but then by the
end of that year I thought you could
just sell them back to the bookstore but
you can't the bookstore was like yeah
we'll give you five bucks for that one
and this one's obsolete I was like I'm
using the next versions yeah yeah this
has changed yeah I was so mad you stole
my money huh so then from that point on
I would look at was like no books are
five bucks like I'm not gonna buy this
thing and I would like share textbooks
with multiple friends and we would
photocopy them and have these nice
binders of well printed yeah shared
books yeah because that was my money you
know I was like $89 if that takes me
nine hours at minimum wage to make that
back in high school so I'm not gonna
spend that just to just to have a giant
book that's should be on a digital
format anyway because at that time
digital stuff was already invented even
it was a long time ago so why are they
even giving us paper books yeah
so you got to get mad when things are
expensive like housing like you don't
stay in the dorm room unless it's
competitive with off-campus rentals mmm
it's sharing with roommates and in both
the price and quality mm-hmm so and you
don't have a car when you're a student
because you don't have any money cars
are a rich luxury person's gas powered
racing wheelchair so why should you have
one when you don't even have enough
money to pay cash for your for your
student yeah for your courses so that
kind of stuff cuts your bills a lot
big-time yeah I mean I think folks who
take this gap year between high school
and university if they choose to do it
it's super valuable for many reasons and
that's one of them like you see how much
work it actually takes to pay for a you
know 50 grand a year education yeah if
it's a gap working year
I mean I've also heard of taking gap
years to travel to go drink beers in
Thailand yeah with other people's money
and that's also something I was against
as a kid so this is where my
non-privileged upbringing probably
turned out to be an advantage because I
was thinking well how could people go
traveling like that cost money which I
don't have so that's automatically out
of the question and secondly I need to
get to the other side of this hump of
the engineering degree because that's
where the money is so I'm gonna start as
soon as possible mm-hmm I don't want to
delay it at all because then I won't
have the money ever yeah that's a great
point so I'm just kind of curious work
what'd you think about planning for the
future given that you have such an
influence now among you know millions of
people you know if if the I assume
millions of people yeah I don't know if
that's I would like to know the real
number but let's just say there's if
there is influence then yeah what's the
exact question well I plan for it
wellyou're because you can kind of be
prescriptive to a certain extent you
know say you know climate change happens
or maybe the US economy doesn't
necessarily like keep up the pace it has
been what how do you feel about that how
do you how do you plan for it and how do
you recommend other people plan for it
oh right you mean so if things are not
perfect like they have been since the
last recession since we came out of it
yeah how do you make your life until you
I guess you could say and luckily the
the same principles that get you to
early retirement in good times are the
same ones that make you more crash-proof
in bad times so which is not designing a
bunch of costs into your life that don't
have to be there and not you know not
compromising your health because that's
just another cost if you're if you get
sick or if you're less productive
because you're less healthy mmm so all
the basic principles are mustache iam
like building multiple skills reduce
increases your production living to live
learning to live efficiently so that
decreases your consumption hanging out
you know building social connections
with people of all different sorts so
you have like a mesh of people to lean
on and that you can help all that stuff
is the same things we would do in the
event of a zombie apocalypse as well so
it works in all in all times okay
cool well I think we're good do you have
any closing words for mustache Ian's or
people on the road to early retirement
oh man you just sprung that one on me no
I don't have any closing words I'm just
a general words as they go as life goes
on type of person so okay I'll be the
next time I have words that will appear
on the blog all right thanks man thank
you
you